did you catch the vp debate last night
if you did if you saw it you've got to
think the biden people are beginning to
regret
picking kamala harris for the ticket
maybe on paper
harris made sense as the old guy's
running mate apparently she did
but on stage not appealing to put it
mildly
unless you enjoyed being lectured in
school by substitute teachers who tried
to mask their insecurity with aggression
you probably don't want four more years
of that even 90 minutes of it was hard
to take
the good news is we did learn at least
one important new thing from watching
we learned how democrats plan to use
identity politics going forward
we already knew that identity politics
is an effective maybe the most effective
way to get democrats to the polls in an
election year
that's why they do it what we learned
last night is that identity politics has
a bigger purpose
it is the justification that democrats
will use to tear down our centuries old
system of government
and replace it with one party rule with
themselves in charge
the evidence came toward the end of last
night's debate when mike pence asked
harris
what the moderator didn't ask but should
have does she and biden plan to pack the
supreme court of the united states
does the bide administration intend to
convert our third branch of government
into a partisan super legislature
with lifetime tenure it's a pretty
simple question
it's a vital question political courts
are the hallmark of banana republics and
dictatorships
we don't want that here yet for weeks
joe biden and kamala harris have refused
to say what they will do if elected
so last night pence pushed again here's
what happened
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
pack the supreme court to get your way
joe and i are very clear
the american people are voting right now
and it should be their decision
about who will serve on this most
important body
for a lifetime thank you senator
harrison
susan are voting right now they'd like
to know if you and joe biden are going
to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
of course yeah let's talk about packing
the court then let's talk about this
yeah i'm about to
and do you know that of the 50 people
who president trump appointed to the
court of appeals for lifetime
appointments not one is black
this is what they've been doing you want
to talk about packing a court let's have
that discussion
wait a minute you might ask what does
court
packing have to do with the number of
black judges
on the federal circuit courts of appeals
those seem like completely unrelated
concepts
was kamala harris trying to dodge the
question unfortunately she was not
dodging it
she was answering the question and she
was answering it honestly believe it or
not
if she and joe biden win next month they
will indeed pack the supreme court
they'll justify doing that in the name
of diversity
they will tell you the trump
administration is racist for not
selecting judges
based on the color of their skin they'll
tell you that nine is a very racist
number of supreme court seats
in fact it's the number some dead white
guy came up with a long time ago
see it's racist they'll tell you we need
to diversify the court and of course
that means
a super majority of partisan democrats
that's what they're going to tell you
for now they're not telling you anything
though joe biden repeated that position
today
i'll know my opinion of court packing
when the election is over now look
i know it's a great question you all and
i don't blame you for asking it
but you know the moment i answer that
question
the headline in every one of your papers
will be about that
did you hear that has any presidential
candidate in history ever used that line
you feel like all
lines have been used before but this one
i can't answer your question because if
i do answer it everyone will talk about
my answer
what does that even mean truly we have
no idea what it means
but we do know that none of this is
going to stop with supreme court
this summer barack obama used a funeral
service to tell us that the filibuster
is a relic
of jim crow it's a racist procedure any
senate procedure that limits the power
of the democratic party is
by definition racist that's the new
standard
identity politics is the most powerful
political weapon
they have don't take it at face value
there's a purpose
for it and of course identity politics
is also a handy shield we saw that
repeatedly last night
at one point pence pointed out that
democrats have attacked amy coney
barrett for the crime of being catholic
that seems out of bounds how did harris
respond
she responded by describing herself as a
person of faith
first of all joe biden and i are both
people of faith
and it's insulting to suggest that we
would
knock anyone for their faith
oh come on a person of faith now
how what exactly does kamala harris
worship apart from power
honestly we'd like to know if you know
tell us she seems like the most secular
candidate ever to run for national
office that's not an attack on her by
the way
plenty of decent secular people but it's
true
not that truth matters in this case for
the purposes of last night's debate
kamala harris identified as a person of
faith and that's all that matters
the progressive left understands race
and gender and yes religious faith
as means to an end they're identities
they don't have independent
meanings they are tools used to win
arguments
and achieve power kamala harris cycled
through various
identities last night i'm speaking she
barked again and again when
mike pence tried to respond to her in
other words i'm a woman
that's why you're interrupting me the
vice president said when asked
well why didn't you all tell anybody he
said because the president wanted people
to remain
calm well let's go i don't know but
susan
this is important and i want to add but
if mr vice president i'm speaking i have
i'm speaking
joe biden has been very clear he will
not raise taxes on anybody who makes
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year appeal the trump tax cuts
mr vice president i'm speaking well i'm
speaking
i'm so glad we went through a little
history lesson let's do that a little
more
in 1816 i'd like you to answer the
question mr vice president
speaking i'm speaking okay
democrats thought that was appealing
what world do they live in
they must have because already you can
find t-shirts and mugs online with the
phrase
i'm speaking obviously it was planned
kamala air says many allies in the media
were impressed too they knew exactly
what kamala harris was really saying
i'm a woman and they were unanimous in
their conclusion mike pence who's been
married to the same woman for 35 years
interrupted kamala harris because
he's a sexist who hates women
she was not overly assertive throughout
this entire debate
this was it was a man mansplainer in
chief
mike mansplainer i understand that he
repeatedly interrupted her
he demanded well he also repeatedly
interrupted the other woman in the room
which
is the moderator who seemed to at some
point lose control of him
you have a reporter and a woman
candidate and both of them you're
interrupting both of them you're
attacking
not a good sign but i think a lot of
people were noticing some mansplaining
going on tonight he kept
interrupting his moderator a woman and
his opponent
a woman some may feel that that showed
lack of respect
well let me start with pence he was
patronizing which drove
all the women crazy mike pence who was
mostly polite but did
interrupt and did do the guy thing of
demanding and getting
more time to speak than the woman oh
so as a scientific matter the category
women doesn't really exist neither is
the category men
because gender fluidity is real you can
choose your gender
but women are also simultaneously so
different from men that you have to
treat them in a completely different way
or you're a bad person are you following
this
and if you do that you're mansplaining
that's what they told us on tv last
night what kind of adult uses the term
mansplaining
get some self-respect by the way
think it through why did no one accuse
donald trump or joe biden of
mansplaining when they repeatedly
interrupted each other at last
week's debate whatever when a man
interrupts a woman it must be sexism
there's no other explanation in order to
treat women equally we have to treat
them very differently from men so as not
to disturb their delicate sensibilities
it's insane and if the consequences for
this country weren't so
serious it would be amusing but they
don't even follow their own rules which
makes sense because the rules are
incoherent
last night the same people who denounced
pence as a sexist
went on at length about kamala harris's
charming girlish smile pamela harris
with a smile pushed back on mike pence's
repeated talking over time
and interrupting her so did you notice
the smile
that was on her face all the time when
she and that's hard when you're getting
interrupted constantly
every shot kamala harris when she's
looking at him
would smile she had a smile on her face
far
more than than pence ever had a smile on
his face kamala on the other hand
she was strong she was in command and
she had a hint of joy
you sense that there is joyfulness in
her spirit
obviously these are partisans obviously
these are people who are projecting
their own
sad empty hollow personal lives onto the
rest of the country
no matter what they're doing though it's
just too stupid for a great nation
at one point during the debate mike
pence to his credit tried to elevate it
a little bit talk about something that
actually matters the habit we've all
fallen into
of thinking of each other as members of
categories rather than as human beings
and as individuals as creations of god
that's how people of faith think by the
way
senator harris whatever they're calling
this kind of thinking right now
intersectionalism identity politics
critical race theory systemic racism
whatever
it's terrible it's a cul-de-sac it will
wreck the country
so mike pence tried to make that point
no he said last night the police aren't
systemically racist
whatever that is it's a fundamentally
good country now that's a conversation
to be worth having that would be
edifying
that does mean something but the media
ignored it they spent most of the night
talking about a house fly
that landed on mike pence's forehead at
one point when they were talking about
systemic racism i think it's very
interesting timing
that a fly would land on mike pence's
head at that particular time
when he said that there really wasn't
systemic racism i
saw the fly basically go on say what i
mean it was very interesting
it was very interesting what you have
here what you have so often
is yet another unhappy rich lady
complaining about oppression
no wonder the american population is so
desperately unhappy
look at who's leading them the most
privileged in our society never stop
whining about their own lives it's
unbearable
in fact if we're being honest about it
and this was one bright spot from last
night's debate
some annoying behavior aside it was a
pretty respectful affair all things
considering
considering we're three weeks out in the
most intense political year of our
lifetimes
there were a handful of minor
interruptions as you would expect but
for the most part
both of them pence and harris kept to
their time limits in fact they spoke
roughly for the same amount of time last
night
that's worth noting maybe celebrating
and yet for our media class the main
takeaway was still that mike pence is a
sexist and by the way there was a fly on
his forehead
we definitely deserve better than that
the presidential election is a little
over three weeks from right now we still
have no idea who's going to win
but no matter who does win in november
there's one thing for certain this
country
desperately needs a better class of
leaders
in charge these people are ridiculous